il ya des événements indésirables dans
tous les ehpad puisque je disais la
perfection n'est pas possible dans ce
domaine manque de personnel maltraitance
front de services sociaux et
rétrocommissions la publication du livre
les fossoyeurs du journaliste victor
castanet jettent une lumière crue sur la
gestion des ehpad privé à but lucratif
orpea au delà du scandale c'est tout
l'appareil des établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes qui est remise en question
alors le cas au rhdp a été isolée où est
le symbole d'un système gangréné par les
dysfonctionnements
réponse dans facture
[Musique]
en france aujourd'hui
7573 ehpad accueille chaque année
environ 600 huit mille résidents 50 %
des places en ehpad sont dans le secteur
public 28 % dans le secteur associatif
ou privés non lucratifs et 22% dans le
secteur privé lucratif dans ces
établissements l'âge moyen à l'entrée
est de 85 ans et huit mois l'espérance
de vie s'allonge et donc et personne en
fait entre un ehpad de plus en plus tard
avec de plus en plus de pathologies
et donc elles ont de plus en plus besoin
d'un accompagnement renforcé pour tous
les actes de la vie quotidienne un
résident on n'est pas cumuler en moyenne
7,9 pathologie problème physique
troubles chroniques du comportement
syndromes démentiels ou maladie
d'alzheimer et le problème c'est qu'il
n'ya pas eu une augmentation en
corrélation du nombre de soignants par
rapport au degré de dépendance des
résidents dès aujourd'hui les personnes
qui vivent en établissement les
personnes quel que soit le type
d'établissement d'ailleurs publics
associatifs ou commerciaux ou que les
personnes qui sont accompagnés à
domicile le sont insuffisamment parce
qu'il ya trop peu de personnel visage
leur disposition le manque de personnel
serait ainsi la première source de
dérives en ehpad dans les établissements
comptent seulement un aide-soignant pour
quatre résidents et un infirmier pour
presque 17 personnes âgées en moyenne un
ratio insuffisant qui conduirait à ce
que l'on appelle de la maltraitance
institutionnelle la maltraitance
institutionnelle ces maltraitances
involontaire qui est générée en fait par
l'organisation le site m c'est quelque
chose qui se voit vraiment
quotidiennement et
tout au long de la journée c'est à dire
que dès le matin voilà j'ai pu me rendre
dans un ehpad ou publics où il va y
avoir trois aides soignants pour une
quarantaine de résidents ça veut dire
que c'est c'est chaque aides-soignants
aura une dizaine dans une douzaine de
toiles elle a effectué le matin ce qui
est énorme et le soir c'est encore plus
criant c'est à dire que le soir les
aides soignants vont se retrouver voilà
à deux ou trois pour coucher une
quarantaine de résidents en une heure et
demie ce qui revient à 5 minutes par par
résident et même si de nombreux rapports
remis aux pouvoirs publics ont déjà
souligné l'importance d'augmenter les
effectifs dans les établissements
médico-sociaux aucune évolution notable
de leur masse salariale lieu depuis le
plan solidarité grand âge de 2006 sont
aussi mises en cause les agences
régionales de santé et les départements
qui participent au financement des ehpad
un établissement qui doit payer
l'énergie 5 % plus cher qui doit payer
les denrées alimentaires 3 ton sang du
cheikh qui doit payer les salariés 2 %
plus cher est un département qui lui dit
mais moi je vous autorise à augmenter
votre tarif 2 0% et bien de fait vous ne
pouvez pas tout concilier et donc vous
devez bien rogner soit sur le nombre de
salariés soit sur la qualité des
interventions le nombre des
interventions auprès des personnes âgées
ce sous-financement des ehpad se
conjugue avec un manque de personnel
qualifié et un recours aux contrats de
courte durée très important c'est à dire
qu'il ya la moitié des ehpad qui vous
rencontrez des difficultés de
recrutement est donc parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à recruter du personnel
diplômé ils vont avoir recours à donc
des faisant fonction d'être soigné une
des faisant fonction des expériences et
des personnes peut pas forcément de
formation et d'expérience dans le
secteur qui vont être embauchés un
dépassement de fonction qui conduit à un
indice des accidents du travail en ehpad
deux fois supérieur à la moyenne
nationale est même plus élevé que dans
le secteur du btp dans les hautes france
par exemple
la préfecture a dénombré 80 18 accidents
pour 1000 salariés d'établissements
accueillant des personnes âgées sur
l'année 2018 dans notre secteur
d'activité de l'aide aux personnes âgées
non seulement il est au dessus de tout
autre secteur d'activité mais en plus
c'est le seul qui continue de voir
augmenter ses arrêts maladie et ces
accidents du travail l'homme savait ce
partout ailleurs tous financés de la
même manière et sans distinction les
établissements publics associatifs et
privés connaissent donc tous le même
problème de personnel mais un fait les
dix aussi les établissements privés à
but lucratif comme orpéa dégage des
bénéfices
en fait l'objectif de cette boîte comme
toutes les entreprises cotées c'est
avant tout de satisfaire les
actionnaires sur ce point le groupe
orpea se porte bien puisqu'il a
distribué 58 millions d'euros de
dividendes à ses actionnaires en 2020 en
pleine crise qu au vide sur un total de
160 millions d'euros de résultat net
très peu habilité à recevoir des
résidents éligibles à l'aide sociale à
l'hébergement ces structures
commerciales par donc fixé librement la
tarification de leur chambre et c'est
l'une de leur principale source de
bénéfices alors que le tarif médian
d'une place en ehpad et 2008 142 euros
par mois dans le public il est de 2700
10 euros dans le privé lucratif avec des
tarifs pouvant grimper jusqu'à 8000
euros s'ajoute à cela dans la sphère
orpea diverses accusations de
rationnement de nourriture et de
matériel de soins mais aussi de fraude
aux services sociaux sur les effectifs
ou encore le fait que l'entreprise ait
perçu des rétrocommissions la mécanique
la plus simple pour gonfler les
bénéfices c'est de réduire les coûts de
l'entreprise
les coûts de l'entreprise dans le cas de
d'orpea dans un groupe spécialisé dans
la dépendance
ah et bien c'est de limiter
le personnel sait imiter aussi tous les
soins qu'ils sont
les prestations qui sont
accordés aux résidents ce système de
rétrocommissions avaient d'ailleurs déjà
été dénoncée en 2014 par claude evin
ancien ministre de la santé est alors
directeur général de l' ars d'île de
france il avait alerté sur ses pratiques
dans les ehpad du groupe korian deuxième
leader du secteur arrivé au début des
années 2000 pour élargir l'offre
d'hébergement aux personnes âgées ces
ehpad privé à but lucratif qui ne sont
pas toutes cotées en bourse font
aujourd'hui face à une remise en cause
de leurs modèles un modèle qui comme
celui des ehpad publics et associatifs
n'est que peut contrôler les contrôles
dans les ehpad effectué après un
signalement ou par auto saisine peuvent
être décidées par trois autorités
différentes le préfet représentant de
l'état dans le département où
l'établissement est implanté le conseil
départemental où l' agence régionale de
santé pour autant sur les années 2017
2018 et 2019 il n'y a eu que trois à 50
contrôles selon les régions d'après le
défenseur des droits un rythme que le
gouvernement souhaite accélérer suite à
la sphère orpea ce qui reviendrait à de
constater que l'échec des derniers
quinquennat sur l'autonomie d'après
romain gizolme les propositions
d'engager plus de contrôle elles doivent
se discuter parce qu'aujourd'hui très
clairement à notre sens ça na n'aura
aucun intérêt et que voulez-vous que
contrôle de plus l'état aujourd'hui s'il
vient contrôler et bien il va contrôler
que les professionnels s'épuise que les
personnes âgées sont insuffisamment
accompagner et tout cela pour quoi parce
qu'ils financent insuffisamment
[Musique]